one of the things great companies are
very good at is retention retention how
do you retain how do you keep your best
people to not want to leave you and and
Steve Jobs said everything is about
vision and Tony Hsieh from Zappos said
everything is about culture right so you
know if you have vision people going to
stay with you forever and then Tony Shea
would say it's about culture because
people want to have fun and all this
other stuff and I think if you really
think about the great companies like
Walt Disney you think about vision and
culture if you think about companies
like Apple you think about vision and
culture when you think about Google you
think about vision and culture when you
think about Amazon it's a vision and
culture where are we going and this is
our culture and it's very very critical
on being able to make a great
environment where you're working out
that people want to come and belong to
and they want to buy into it long term
but they also want to have a blast while
they're working there so today we're
going to talk about mainly culture and
before I get into this message it's
going to be let me see how many points
this is it is going to be 25 points I'll
cover on creating a great culture at
your company but I am wearing on
cyberdust shirt you know most people
tell you to practice safe sex safe sex
they say practice safe sex right I think
I believe in practice and safe texting
this is why you cyber does this is love
to our friend our buddy Mark Cuban mark
this is dedicated to you Cindy thanks
for the shirt love the shirt and love
using cyber that's anyways that's the
plug for cyber does let me get right
into it
so how do you create a great environment
for a company now money I'm gonna make
the points and give stories as well so
you know how to do it for yourself this
is stuff that you can do for your
business yourself point number one
okay create a great culture where a
create a culture where feedback is open
your place you want to hear feedback
right not error against pure feedback
have we thought about doing this what if
we can do this what if we can do that
and a type of environment where people
want to give their opinions people want
to give their ideas people want to you
know share with you on what they're
doing that's working for them but also a
place where everything is about what can
we do to improve as a team what can we
do to do this better
can we make this thing better how can we
make the system better how can we make
this website by the how Kume
everything's about something being
better because everybody's got their
eyeballs on something on saying hey I
thought about this one thing we do if we
do this this this could this make it
better
possibly what if it does right so it's a
culture of constantly thinking about
making things better - pranks I'm big on
pranks ever since being a kid I love
pranks and yes I said prank like pran K
pranks pranks when I was in a military
when I was a kid I put pranks on people
all the time my friends would tell you
what kind of pranks I pulled some of
them are pretty bad pranks if you
remember a frank rizzo and what was what
was that movie is called Jerky Boys or
something like that with those guys with
poor pranks on people it was hilarious
and then we pulled pranks in school I
put pranks on my teachers I pull pranks
on my parents pranks on my aunties you
know my one of my aunties didn't like I
haven't told you the story she didn't
like worms she couldn't stand warm so I
would you know eat gummy bears and tell
her you know you want to eat a warm and
I would eat a warm and she would just be
completely disgusted by I would come and
I would say hey did you hear about what
happened and she said what I say you
will not believe who married who who
marry do Mike Tyson and Madonna are
getting married no way they just got
married today Mike Tyson and Madonna
no and then my auntie would flip out
calling everybody relatives saying did
you hear Mike Tyson married Madonna but
I'm big on pranks military we did a lot
of pranks work we did a lot of pranks
Mario is epic when it comes up to
pulling pranks Mario one time pulled a
prank on one of our branch managers Chad
and he brought a paper that was FedExed
in and he put the envelope in there as
if it's coming from FedEx and in the
FedEx it's a letter with the same
company letterhead saying the following
five agents have been terminated
according to IRS SEC code 5:30 I which
is 5:30 I said BMW so he puts IRS SEC
code 5:30 I and as he's given this to
the branch manager Chad he puts a camera
on the side to record the whole thing
this is hilarious he puts the cameras SH
out we got this from FedEx
I just wanted to give it to you first
and Chad stays and
Mario stands right in front of him and
Chad opens it and he says what why'd he
get terminated according to IRS SEC code
530 I've never heard of this before oh
my and he starts panicking and it says
call this number so he calls this number
furious I need to talk to your manager I
just got a letter here that's such and
such and such and such agent are getting
terminated because of the IRS SEC Co
530i how is that possible
furious this whole thing's on video and
the gentleman on the phone says let me
place you on hold
so he's placed him on hold seven minutes
he's on hold seven minutes they come
back later says look you put me on hold
I need to speak to your manager why the
following agents got the SEC IRS code
5:30 out that they're getting terminated
how is that possible we run a very
compliant business here and the guy says
sir do you know where you call yes I do
know where I call this is Hooters he
says where this is odors a black yep
Georgia
he says Hooters he says yes he looks and
Mario Mario's and tears cracking up
trying to hold themselves cameras right
there everybody's cracking was one of
the most incredible pranks that the more
you pulled on one of our guys and then
these guys come in when you anytime you
create a culture of pranks you gotta
know it's gonna come back on you as well
these guys pulled a prank on me one time
set up the whole thing with cameras
everywhere in my office I sat in the
chair and make the sound of a law loud
honk horn but you know pranks loosens
people up you know in the world of
sports they say play loose because when
you play loose you're playing to gain
your love when you play tight you throw
an interception when you play tight you
get a turnover when you play type you
don't swing well you strike out when you
play tag you don't make the right cup
you know tackles when you plate you just
you're not able to play well pranks tend
to lose some people up when you have
that going on your environment I know
this sounds very very different to some
of you that are watching to say well
you've got to be very very serious if
you want to be like IBM and get your
butt whooped by Apple you be a you know
guy like in a box that everything is
about this is how we do it cuz this is
how we know you got to loosen it up a
little bit and change if you want to
just point number three competition I am
very big on creating a competitive
environment and I know they're almost
like contradictory but let me explain to
what I mean by competition
friend of mine the army Bradford and he
and I and another guy named Larry
McElroy a good buddy of mine
he's now loud on where he's living at
her but I love these guys these guys are
good buddies on my until today we
regularly communicate so we were very
competitive and everything to us was
competition everything so we would talk
about you know who can do the most
pushups who can do to Moses who can do
it and it was always competing who can
bench the most who can curl the most who
can run the most everything was a spirit
of competition now there's a lot of
people you got to realize this lots of
journalists lots of magazines lots of
popular publications cannot stand when I
talk about competition because today
it's competition is very bad because you
shouldn't beat people well then you
shouldn't watch sports because in sports
somebody beats somebody you should stop
watching boxing US FC baseball
basketball hockey Olympics stop watching
Olympics
stop watching Soccer World Cup do you
know why billions of people around the
world watch the Olympics and soccer
because of competition that's why
because the best performers in the world
come and beat another record so anybody
who tells you they don't like
competition ask him if they like sports
you'll see how much contradiction to
have in their lives
the only reason many people don't like
competitions because they've lost a
couple times very bad and they were
humiliated and that feeling stings here
and they don't want to do something
about it I love competition I've got my
butt whooped so many times it's not even
funny but I'm all about competition will
do competition see who can do the most
pushups will do right here will do the
competition so we can come out with the
best ideas will do competition see who
can do the everything's about
competition matter of fact I just put a
recent competition together on who can
make one who can make who can decorate
their cubicles the best at the home
office staff right and they can do
whatever they want in first place gets a
$250 gift card - what did I say Amazon
or something like that right whatever
they want so he want your yours is gonna
be around what thing you said Led
Zeppelin he's a big let's level heavy
metal guys so we'll see maybe you're
going to show it on next episode how
it's going to look like and that 30 days
to fix their place up I love it go fix
it up make it look good on how I want to
do it one time I remember and I love
this because the more people are seeing
a competitive environment you're always
going to get a better
the everything is going to improve and
constitu get better one time I was in it
in my office this is 13 years ago and a
guy came and he started talking smack to
everybody and he said you know I'm 41
years old and I'm coaching a but what's
the school that was across the street
from victory in Birmingham Birmingham
Birmingham high school he says I can
kick everybody's butt and sprinting and
running in all this and I'm dressed in
suit and I said scuzz just don't
irritate me a lot and he says I'm faster
than all of you so I said let's go step
outside I'll race you says but you got
dress shoes and I'm going to do to my
socks now this is a little bit crazy I
know people will say this as well so we
go outside and there's a bunch of people
waiting I said let's go 100 yards to
pick a car so it's like at this victory
in babul office I said let's pick 100 so
we mark the car so let's race to that no
prom so he's in his shorts he just came
from practice okay it's like 10:30 at
night 10 o'clock at night I take off my
tie I'm winning dress shirts dress pants
and I take off my shoes I'm more in
black socks it's already ready
so I said guys give us a signal 6 1 2 3
we start racing so we start racing and I
beat him and I beat him pretty good it
was a pretty good race and now I'm
beating them and all of a sudden I'm
looking back and looking at I'd be like
why are my feet so sticky well I look
down on my feet my entire socks have
been pulled back and my skins been
pulled back there's foot marks on the
ground of you-know-what blood literally
for week and a half I couldn't walk now
somebody could say this is what they
could say this is absolutely you can
call it foolish crazy whatever you want
to call it I would agree with you I
would say you're right I wouldn't be
baited but that's the spirit of a
competitor you want to find out if you
can do it better you want to find out if
we can you know improve something and
when there's in a competitive
environment people come up with better
ideas
you know never combative because
combative is something if the top allows
that to happen then that's the problem
of the top I'm not talking combative I'm
talking competitive I'm talking
competitive not combative but a
competitive environment number four
humor use humor all the time I love
using humor all the time it loosens
things up if you look at again I said it
earlier with the pranks part but humor
is different you know just
can how does in a military why is it
that anybody that goes into military if
you ask him how it is everybody thinks
you're so serious you're so this you're
so that you're serious when it's you
know wartime you know in sports you're
serious when it's playoff fort we got to
go win and make it happen of course
we've been practicing to win and we got
to win because you don't win you and
getting a championship and why else are
you playing the game to do what you just
say you're in the NBA no you're playing
to win a championship right you're going
to war to either win the war or create
some kind of a peace treaty with the
other enemy but you're not going to work
you're dying you ain't playing a game to
lose you plan to compete and win right
to dominate now now with that being said
would that being said in the military
almost anybody I've met that's been in a
Marines Air Force Army Navy whatever it
is your sense a certain level of humor
maybe a little bit of sarcasm very witty
why because if you're in the military
and if you don't have humor sarcasm and
and you're very sensitive you're going
to get crushed in a military same
happens on sports teams if you're on
sports teams you'll sense a lot of look
at him smack-talking
if you're too sensitive you're not going
to be able to make you're playing
against a guy like Chris Paul or Gary
Payton or Kobe or Jordan they will
demoralize you but in sports you got to
play that game there's humor so there's
a little bit going on in a culture that
we created and I think it gets everybody
to be tougher funner and it just it just
makes for a better environment when
there's humor being above next one five
music I'm very big on music I think
music being played loosens people up and
energizes people you know there was
always great songs you can play
throughout the day I like music playing
constantly whether it's plain don't stop
believin by your journey or it's you
know Josie's got was that one song I
would always play Josie's gotta go
talk it over so many long to say you
know you I just want to lose you I just
want to lose your life tonight I just
want to something like that anyways we
would play that up or do one by eros
madhurima oh my the other day we play
dream on here I got emotional just
listen to cuz it fires you up every time
we would have like let's just say
session was getting started was about to
start we would like to play the song the
theme song of the Chicago Bulls remember
and now the star lineup what is Chicago
we would start it off like that people
are fired up right it absolutely jacks
you a music plays a very big role in
culture six higher the right kind of
people that fit the culture it's very
very important do not try to force
somebody who doesn't fit the culture in
your culture I'll tell you why because
when you try to force that it doesn't
work out and everybody's uncomfortable
everybody is uncomfortable and generally
for us we'll interview somebody and
sometimes the interview process will
talk and last question will bring
somebody on board or even in an office
we would bring in you know sales side I
would talk to them how you did sorry
that are you this and you'll generally
know somebody who fits the culture very
well and there are those that are coming
and say whoa this is I don't know if I
can do this you know and they're very
much liking to be a corporate absolute
like wait where you go to the job and no
one talks to everybody and we're kind of
like robots and that's not the culture I
want to create not at all so they don't
fit the culture so sometimes a person
you may hire and they'll come into the
culture they'll get filtered out by
themselves through the culture don't
worry about that you're not trying to
retain everybody you want to retain the
type of people that fit the culture that
you have I was in France having
breakfast at Angelenos with my wife and
we're sitting next to a couple and
anybody that always sits next my life to
talk to them and I said so well you guys
speak very good English where are you
from so some work from Chicago so who do
you work for coca-cola sounded like
working for coca-cola I've been with
them for 14 years so what does that mean
to me so we met in coca-cola my wife and
I say so tell me about Co Co Co they
went for 14 minutes my house I have
everything in my house is coca-cola this
is coca-cola that is coca-cola they sold
me on the culture of working for
coca-cola that fires me up because it
tells me how great of a job coca-cola
to create an environment where two
people who are in France not working in
France they're just there to visit her
relatives are fired up to talk about
coca-cola next to a couple other people
who are there for vacation with a few
friends there sharing our culture with
them there is something there you know
when you hire the right type of people
who stick around and fall in love with
the brand next one is seven add your own
personality to it let me explain to what
I mean by personality to it if you're
into sports use sports metaphors if
you're sports show sports if you're
music show it if you're you know rock
show it if you're you know somebody that
likes a biggie show it if you're Tupac
guy show it if you're you know a Taylor
Swift show it if you're into motorcycles
show do you like cars showed your
Mustang 1964 and a half guy showed
you're a Corvette 59 and a half show it
you're a Lambo guy Corbit guy Porsche
guy doesn't matter shows you whoever you
are you like politics you like Aristotle
you like Socrates like you know stoicism
you like show it right things that are
you showed your Laker fan Jets fan
Yankees fan doesn't matter show the
culture that you have if your golf guy
you like certain movies you're a
Scarface person you're a I don't know
you're a casino person you're a you know
gladiator person you're 300 you're about
Braveheart show it it shows call your
ascent of a woman person your note book
person whatever show the culture that
you have and add your personality to it
you have nothing to be embarrassed of of
the way you are that's who you are
show the world people want to know how
you're because you're unique in your own
way eight initiation process we've
always had initiation processes and I
love initiating people when we were at
the army unit we had a lot of initiating
process but that one I can't share with
you because that's more of a private
initiation process I'll share Monday
where if we're at a session together
I'll share that with you but initiation
process are very critical somebody would
get a promotion we'd get them in the
office and we say listen you are now a
senior leader with our affirm so we need
to make sure we initiate you and what do
I was going to do we would turn off the
lights everybody would go further to the
wall but everybody would be shouting at
him
and he would think we're about to jump
him as if we're back in high school and
he would turn on the lights
five seconds late he was always funny to
see them because you would see some that
were like this thinking we're about to
hit them you would see some that already
[ __ ] you would see sucked started like
oh we learned a lot about you this was a
fighter that's great
you see wounds covered up you see one
that just standing there not even know
what's going on right it was great
though we had different types of things
for initiation because I think I think
you got to do that to have fun with it
as you're as you're creating your
environment another one is monthly
contests very exciting to have monthly
contests it doesn't matter what the
monthly contests are it could be
anything you know we can have as big of
a monthly contest as going to Dubai or
going to Tuscany Italy or go into
Caribbean or going to you know Aspen and
staying at st. Regis as big as giving
away Ferrari or giving away a Corvette
or giving away whatever and it could be
as small as given $100 gift card to
Amazon doesn't matter every month have a
contest for something that people are
fighting for it's exciting to keep
getting better and to hunt people want
to stay later to win people spend time
on weekends to improve certain things it
adds to the culture next invest in them
I think I think sometimes we don't
invest into our people enough I'm big on
investing into people I think we need to
invest into people it doesn't matter
what it is if somebody's doing
accounting what can they do to go to a
course that's going to teach them to be
better in accounting if somebody is
doing marketing what can you do to get
better at that if somebody is doing you
know sales what can we do to bring the
best sales speaker if someone wants to
learn how to become more how to sales
when I may bring the Tom Hopkins if
someone wants to be more audacious I may
bring the Grant Cardone if somebody's
you notice your culture is not good at
goal-setting you may bring Brian Tracy
if you're you know you need vision you
may bring your Mark Cuban if you're you
know you need somebody that's talking
about what it is to have the right
manners you can make if it's marriage
you may bring somebody if it doesn't
matter bring something that's constant
education to your field force it will
always give the return on the investment
you made for that speaker what was that
oh it's the sprouts I thought it was
like sprinkles going on
okay read together I'm very big on
reading together I think it's very
critical for people to be reading
together we do monthly book club every
single month y'all already run a book
club called the entrepreneurs book club
but every single month
for as long as we've been around we read
a book and everybody turns in a report
and we read it together for every single
month as long as we've been around we've
read a book together because it's
something that I expect everybody to
invest into themselves and improve and
if you get into the culture and if you
don't like reading you're gonna be
filtered out because it's just the
culture that we have we like people to
improve we were going through the
interview process the other day and one
of the people that made it to the last
interview with me she went through three
different people before me and I sat and
I said I asked one question I said how
much do you read so I haven't read ever
since I graduated college I said why not
since I have kids I have this address so
have you read any business books no what
do you read I don't read well that's a
problem you know because we're big on
reading so you got to be willing to
improve and constantly working on
yourself next incentivize incentivize
them for anything that this is different
than contests it could be something very
small that if you do this and if you
notice somebody that's doing their part
you know make them feel good by doing
certain things on the side incentivize
people to go out there and do something
you do this the best will do this you do
that the best you'll do this if you do
this I'll do this if you do that we'll
do this there's always a you know way of
getting people to want to move in
getting certain things going past just
certain contest next celebrating
birthdays together it's a small thing
but listen it means a lot to people just
today I was one of my friend's birthday
today
Erica del Toro you get some love on this
video Erica happy birthday to you her
birthday and so I sent a message to her
I told her exactly how I feel about her
and she said you know just the most
amazing message I got etc etc and we
sing a certain way you know we have a
certain thing that we do when we sing
it's different our song has certain
whistling to it and everybody now sings
that way it's just just how we sing
right and you know what we'll pick in an
office whatever office we are in if it's
one of the leaders birthday chip and
five bucks get something small bring the
cake surprise him and try to find a way
to do where he or she expected the least
because no one was expecting it because
the smart ones you can't surprise them
so you know birthdays are a very big
thing to know that you know you're
paying attention to their personal lives
as well next one is cards I'm big on
sending cards to folks I think it shows
that you take the additional time most
people
want to do that because it's like time
for cards why would I want to send a
card I would say we average twenty to
thirty thousand cards per year I think
last year was twenty-seven thousand
cards something like that I may be off
by a few thousand but that's the number
that I get 15 emotion emotion emotion
may explain what I mean by a motion
motion motion when somebody is not in a
good place when somebody is confused
when somebody and we are going to go
through certain phases in our lives you
know you ask what do you want but what
is an ideal situation for you what are
you doing it for why are you here why'd
you get excited about this tell me about
the goals you have and and I could tell
you what's Mario's dream car I could
tell you why what's the dream situation
for you know what some of our people
want to do I could go through it because
it's important to me because I want to
know what things they want to do I could
tell you many of our leaders on what
their goals were what their car was the
house they want to get the place they
want to live the place they want to
travel it's important because at the end
of the day a company excels and does
very well when a lot of people's dreams
within it become a reality as well now
you know it's all based on contribution
and value it's not like oh you want this
I'll do this for if you stick around no
it's you do this and if you do this you
have the possibility to earn XYZ so it's
still a merit system that they got to go
earn but it's knowing what people want
to do long term with their lives as well
another one is this next one point over
16 don't be too lopsided on one type of
a sex like gender don't just be an
environment that's only male driven or
only female driven unless if that's your
business let's just say your business is
you know make up okay it's going to be
probably female driven right if your
business is I don't know whatever it is
for certain things that men will do it
may be male driven but if it's not if
it's Disney it can be both sexes you
know if it's technology it can be both
sexes if it's if it's sales it's both
for us you know we're 54% in our company
are filled with women it's not men it's
54% of women 46% men so it's pretty much
50/50
but I like to ask both sides you know I
like to ask ladies hey what do you think
we can do with the company on things
that you want to see and what men what
do you want to see because sometimes
there may be a lot of competition on one
side and the other side is and there's
no empathy and compassion and emotion
hey we need to go in sometimes you may
go way way too much empathy compassion
and emotion and you have kind of no
competition and so there's always a good
balance just like politics Republicans
cancer you have to do this and then if
we go too far decide we're in trouble
and then you know Democrats may say we
do this and if we go too much it's like
we are right now we're in trouble
generally this is good to be right in
the middle so get feedback from both
sides on what we can do to improve the
company or the environment that you're
creating next point number 17 surprise
your team surprise your team surprise
your team I mean as much as you can't
surprise your team
just last month you know was so proud of
our guys what they did I brought several
masseuse to the office surprised
everyone put a massage bed in an office
and everyone when I got a massage for
themselves and they came out like they
were in heaven you know the look on your
face when you come out of massage it
looks like you just got done it looks
good when you just got that getting a
massage you know what I'm talking about
look it's like man I am so relieved they
were so happy when they got the massage
surprise guys today we're gonna go watch
a movie let's go watch a movie hey guys
today we're gonna go grab something to
eat let's go grab something to eat you
know we're going to go to this place you
know just six weeks ago seven weeks ago
we figured out what the best cars that
are you know top leaders liked and I
decided to surprise them and put
blindfold the video is going to come out
here next week or two I'll put it I'll
share with value Taemin as well you know
put a blindfold on them and walk them
all the way through in Vegas with
hundreds of people around and I rendered
you know we got what is it nine cars was
a nine cars we got to McClaren's we got
a Lambo
we got a Ferrari two we got two Ferraris
a Ferrari California Ferrari four or
five eight rows rows guys ghosts we got
a Bentley I'm missing one an Aston
Martin db9 convertible we got all this
and they're standing right in front of
it and someone's revving the car mmm and
you see them shaking it was unbelievable
reaction right they opened it oh man
then we went and had dinner at Dell
Frisco's and James Bond room and you
know saw the presentations of how the
wine bottle opens up in Las Vegas you
should see this two million dollar a
wine a what'd he call it that's not a
cellar it's like a wine up what would
you call that Mari that thing that opens
up with wine bottles with something
called James pots a million bucks James
Bond or something like that anyways it's
just beautiful and we had dinner
you know everybody's there we're having
a great time everyone everybody was
surprised and it adds to it you know in
Dubai we were in Dubai six months ago we
decide to rent a yacht you know and in
the yacht we decided to have a yacht
party and just do lamb chops and steak
and food and dinner and jumping off the
yacht at 128 degree temperature in Dubai
to surprise the guys and just had a
phenomenal time we had a great time
together these are memories we're gonna
have for the rest of our lives but it's
bonding its relationship it's fun what
are we gonna do it in life anyways just
be you know to yourself and extremely
serious all the time and you die in what
happens you die alone in a cemetery end
video alone for the rest of your life
stuck in is that way now it's enjoying
the whole purpose of what you're doing
anyways with with the environment you're
creating next get to know your people I
think a lot of times there is this CEO
and you are someone else and listen you
can't get too close to me or we can do
all this other stuff know the reason why
there's not time to get closest maybe
there just isn't time but there isn't a
I am better than you because I have this
title right I am better than you because
they have this position it means nothing
it means nothing it means nothing
let me tell you you know position you
can call yourself any positions you want
if somebody else doesn't see you as a
CEO you're not a CEO you can say your
seal it doesn't matter nobody else sees
you as a CEO it's it's treatment of
people so what we did a few months back
is we went on bought an RV we wrapped
the RV and we decided to come up with
something called the startup
entrepreneur tour I lived in the RV for
30 days with six of us Mario was one of
them okay six of us it was me
you Merl Tigran Paul and Alex
right and we went from LA to Arizona New
Mexico Dallas Austin San Antonio New
Orleans Jacksonville Miami uh we went
Atlanta Chicago Toronto New York I don't
know what else and all the way around we
went everywhere right
Canada spoke at 16 different cities
Redding San Diego Van Nuys always other
places that we went to and then we came
back and we met everybody we shook
everyone's hands now my anniversary was
on the tour June 26 so I'm on the tour
and its my anniversary not typical oh my
gosh you can't do this you know my wife
and I we pretty much celebrate every
every single week to us this anniversary
because we don't wait for a day to
dictate we're having anniversary so I
flew and my wife and my son and they
went with us with the RV and you know my
kid is with me he's sleeping with me
into bed we had a great time was
phenomenal but we had a chance to shake
everyone's hands we had a chance to go
to everybody and say hey what do you got
going on what's going to talk to people
here's ideas he's we had a blast and we
connected with everyone because the
business is a business of built by a lot
of different people and it takes time
and resources and energy if you sit in a
corner and just hide from everybody all
the time eventually people gonna say man
I don't even know you
how do I if I don't know you how to like
you how do you how do you you know
capture my heart if I don't know you
well it takes a lot of energy it takes a
lot of energy that you got to put into
it this isn't something that happens
overnight next next thing I'll talk
about turn you guys into heroes you know
you got out you got to make sure you're
the top performers people are felt like
they're there above and beyond everybody
else you know I love what a professor
from Cornell University said he said uh
pump up the collective but make sure you
don't forget the individual right pump
up the collective but recognize the
individual because the individual is
someone that is putting maybe twice as
effort everybody else and there are
cases where people put twice as much as
effort everybody else they are more
valuable on a team there is people that
are more valuable on the team you could
be fair with everybody but you can't
treat everybody equally there are people
that are doing above and beyond and they
need to know that they're being
you know above and beyond everybody else
because of their effort that's putting
in where someone wants to go because
five o'clock I'm going on boom 459
they're out this other guys think till
8:30 and you know notice that you don't
recognize that yeah you got to make sure
you recognize what people are putting
the efforts in a tournament to heros
allow for crazy things to happen okay
crazy ideas one time I said listen
before I die guys how about we go out
then broke break a Guinness Book of
World Record how do we do that I have no
idea but let's decide if we can break
the Guinness Book of World Record well
we called Guinness Book of World Record
Guinness World Record and we wanted to
break a record and we decided to break
the record for the most what is it most
of checkers players which they call it
draughts though they call it drown tell
you how do you pronounce that cause
droughts droughts yeah most droughts
right so we they have to fly somebody in
they have to lock the door was a whole
technical thing that you have to do and
I think was a thirty thousand dollars to
do it illegally I mean it was very very
intense and we were in Reno and we broke
the world record for the most checkers
players in one room and you know you
know what's great about it NBC came all
the news stations came the congressman
came the mayor came everybody came and
you know many people left with a world
record this is a Guinness Book of World
Record that we broke it was on national
television they shared the video it went
bonkers when they shared it on their a
Facebook page I don't know how many fans
have on their Facebook page I do know
it's a lot of people hundreds of
thousands that they shared Mari I don't
wanna throw this to you but so we did
that another thing we did is we did a
flash mob in front of Planet Hollywood
and the way we did it was hilarious we
set it up where we created a video with
the choreographer video was sent to
everywhere but it was practicing the
dance in front of Planet Hollywood we
decided to stop in the middle of
everything and act as if somebody was
flirting with one of our guys girlfriend
at that time so everybody thought of
fights about to break out so everybody
shows up to see what's going on and then
they took on put on their shirts PHP and
they did a flash mob - uh what was the
song at that time that was a big kid
size with Gangnam style by psy right
Gangnam style
I think I 150,000 views on YouTube
another one is the Nene dance that our
buddy John did John tends to do a lot of
this stuff with the dance we had the
candy in them that did what they did a
one of the song was a risk Alton what
was the name of the song
it's called the Ritz Carlton I mean that
nothing but yet I don't know how many
millions of people watch that one did
yeah he ran out of there was hilarious
right it was on history I did very well
I went viral on Instagram my buddy you
know here's one that we did we did a
video of like Olympics and here's a
George drinking egg we drank what he
drank eggs and Gaitan you see him eating
spaghetti it's just messy fun fact that
we created that video we have one here
what Hosea's is acting like he's who is
he in this video he is what's the guy's
name
the Rico suave right Rico suave is in %
in Rico suave but look allow for crazy
things allow for crazy things to happen
for the culture because it makes people
want to work for that environment it
makes people want to take it to a whole
different level makes people want to
have fun and makes people want to you
know it just takes it to a whole
different level look sometimes we forget
that you're going to spend more time
with people you work with in your own
family at times especially if you're
building a startup and you're building
your own business why not have fun with
the people you're working with why have
to be so serious why not be able to
create an environment of very high
standards and expectation for people to
perform a very competitive environment
combined with a fun loose prank type of
an environment where you're laughing
yourself to the top that's kind of fun
to do isn't it you'll live longer you
have more fun you make good relationship
you make great memories so when your
time comes to lay down and say you know
I've done my part in the world you're
gonna you know leave this planet with a
lot of great memories that you had that
you built in business as well
accountability everyone's got to be held
accountable this point number 21
everyone's got to be held accountable
but the part of accountability process
is everyone's got to pull their weight
everybody does and a part of
accountability to me is call out so you
can put this point as accountability
slash call out I've always been a fan of
everybody being able to call out every
call out everybody uh I don't want to
wait for instance I have two sons right
let's just say these kids are now 16 and
14 years old and I have a daughter is
going to be born in a couple months and
she's gonna be 16 14 12 years old
hypothetically I don't want them to come
to me every single time and call out and
say he did this did you see this he did
this he didn't know you called him out
won't you cut him out what he did I saw
me at school doing this once you call
him out and pull him aside and tell him
he's not doing he's not doing the right
thing
oh that I was gonna tell you it's okay
you tell me but why are you waiting on
me calling out so the work environment
if somebody is off call them out we have
a pure call-out environment where
permission is given from the top for
anybody to call out everybody why is
that so critical because one everyone is
four it's not necessarily force you're
put in a position to start leading even
though you don't have a leadership
position yet because you realize
sometimes somebody is a leader that no
one knows about you never knew that
person was a leader it's like the Golden
State Warriors you know how people say
you know curry is the MVP the league but
draymond Green is the MVP of Golden
State Warriors no one knows who draymond
Green is but now people do because these
the modern-day Oscar Robertson who's a
leader in the locker room he calls
everybody out now imagine you take drum
draymond green out you think they're
gonna win a championship last year no
way in the world there's no way in the
world they're gonna win a championship
no way in the world because it's a
callout environment I go to some offices
and businesses and I Center I'm like
this i cannot even stay here for another
second everybody i was invited to go to
a place on speak i couldn't wait to
leave couldn't wait to leave because
everybody was sensitive oh we don't say
things like that here really oh my gosh
please send me home already send me home
already I mean everybody's lying to
everybody is that kind of an environment
you want for business doesn't work it's
not effective you got to call them out
if their person is not doing their part
call and I pull your weight you are not
pulling your weight it's affecting
everybody's job so this isn't just about
fun and you know hokey and pranks and
humor and all this other stuff there's a
business side you got to perform
someone's not doing their part you got
to pull them aside and say man what's up
with this spin up with your attitude
lately I don't like your behavior lately
man you can't affect in everybody else's
mood the other day
you got upsetting snapped at the other
guy he didn't do anything to you I just
snap at him yeah oh man you just don't
know what's happening at home bro you
want to go for a walk let's go for a
walk
tell me why what's going on oh you know
me and my girl man we're going to that's
fine bro I promise what my girl I'm
going through this one my kid but we
can't bring that in the workplace so
these are the types of environments that
you got a lot of people to call each
other out next high standards I'm a big
fan of high standards I'm not a fan of
low standards you know just yesterday
entrepreneur put up a video the video
was what the video was it's time for
Millennials to take vacations because
they have too much pressure of not
taking vacations look I mean I've
traveled so many places in the world I
don't even know where I've gone it's
just you name a place I've gone to it
anywhere you name it I've gone I've gone
a lot of if I've had the privilege go
into a lot of different places but I
bust my behind I work hard and I am NOT
a fan of low standards I'm not a fan of
theirs it's a lot easier thing to sell
for someone to say oh poor you you work
too hard honey come home this is too
much it's not good this younger
generation capitalism's making them work
so hard this is not good for your spirit
honey come home I'm sorry that's a low
standard conversation that's a low
standard conversation I like high
standard I guarantee you nothing great
ever happened with low standards I
guarantee you no team ever won a
championship with low standards I
guarantee you no one ever won a gold
medal with low standards I guarantee you
no one ever won a World Cup with low
standards I guarantee you no one ever
ran a 100 billion dollar company with
low standards I guarantee you no one
ever became a president or prime
minister of a country on low standards I
guarantee you no one won mr. Olympia on
low standards nobody high standards no
one does
high standards is what it's at now you
can disagree with thing you don't have
to agree with there's a lot of people
that don't like you when I talk about
high standards but I believe in high
standards I go to restaurants sometimes
or businesses sometimes it drives me
insane when I see a business ran on low
standards I get up and walk out
literally my wife will tell you my
friends will tape I go to a restaurant
and I see something I'm like not with
can we get out of here we get up and
walk out absolutely get up and walk out
went to a sushi spot the other day in
Plano I'm looking for some great sushi
spot some plain old
Alice and I went to this place and my
dad was in town I took him there because
we both like sushi and we sat and I ate
the sushi I was honestly I was
mesmerised I was in love I was in heaven
I was in heaven where you know everybody
in heaven eats sushi and you know what
kind of sushi I'm talking like fatty
tuna sushi the real salmon sashimi and
eat Gouda
real real sushi is what I'm telling that
I might know California I'm talking real
ikura salmon sashimi yellowtail white
tuna albacore type of sushi and I'm
sitting at this man's making it for me
and I'm like man this this guy's on top
of it he's bringing a salmon it's
flawless
they've been in this one you don't put
sauce and I just eat it the way that's
and they knew what they were doing look
around clean clean clean clean clean
clean clean everything's clean right and
I said man this place deserves a 30% tip
you know well go to places like that
these are a big tip we should we should
announcer the places we should say the
name of the place on what it's called
sushi Yokohama Yokohama sushi can we put
a logo of sushi Yokohama up there and
give him some love if you ever share
this video you go to that place as well
let them make make sure they see this
video just phenomenal and I asked the
guy who's the owner of this place I'm
asking my waiter who's the owner of the
place the man making the sushi for me is
the owner of the place that's who ran
the place no wonder the guy that places
ran on high standards when the owner is
at nine o'clock I'm not making sushi for
people on a Friday night on a Friday
night instead of being with his family
that's high standards to me that's a
place I will be loyal to that's a place
I'll give my money to that's a place
I'll give my time to next is sending
gifts I think you got to send gifts to
people and gifts that mean a lot to that
person um you know I'm not just talking
about black and white gifts you know if
somebody has a kid kid send them a book
on parenting if somebody has their first
kid somebody becomes a daddy for the
first time you send them a shirt that
says first time daddy rookie daddy you
know rookie you know whatever it is
there's there's so many ways to to have
fun with the gift side you don't need to
spend $500 on yes although sometimes
that may be a way to do it as well you
know we had one of our girls worked so
hard to them work so hard that you know
I just decided to take you to hold it
from level that
no this was not part of a recognition or
anything it was just a gift I sent them
wondering am i sent him to the most
incredible spawn Chicago and they had a
good time another one I sent him to one
of the most incredible spots in Beverly
Hills montage you know if you're in
Beverly Hills you know that area and
they had a great time it was nothing
there's a few guys that did very good
and out of nowhere to get Ferrari
watches sent to them some guys that I
just think you need to you need to gift
people sometimes with or without a
reason to just give them guys next with
a dress code have fun with a dress code
at this point number 24 funky Friday you
know you don't have to wait for
Halloween to dress up we like to dress
up all the time I'm talking dressing up
like we've done Great Gatsby themes
right will do I don't know a PHP to the
future yeah we did a theme you know you
can probably see a clip here I'm dressed
like the jock right I'm dressed as dot
and then yeah that we'd another one
that's slash and John Mason hi John
what's who Axl John's Axl and Emma I'm
slashing these Axl you know we've done
gaps people were dressing up we've done
so many different things that adds just
a funk component to it to it right now
again some of these things you may watch
and you may say I completely disagree
it's completely fine my suggestion to
you is create an environment where
people want to belong to and they make a
decision to plant their flag to want to
be in business with you forever I love
what Richard Branson once said Richard
Branson said teach everybody your
secrets so they can leave and be your
competitor but treat them so well
so they don't want to let me say one
more time teach everybody your secrets
and concepts on what you do so they can
go out and be your competitor but treat
them so well that they don't want to
give them such a great opportunity that
they don't want to and that's retention
because vision and a culture combined
together creates for an incredible
winning environment people ask so what
books do you recommend there's two books
I would recommend for cultures what I
would recommend two books
get to chatter throw books man the
middle of the video send me a book like
this this is assumed squatchers I do it
I understand it but I'm doing a video
you Center like that and from mildewed
video fish fish is a great book if you
haven't read fish it's a phenomenal book
phenomenal book it's simple I think it's
like 80 pages or something like this let
me see how many pages it is it's like a
ninety nine page pages are like big font
this is another one that's phenomenal by
20 shade this is a must read by our
buddy Tony Hsieh we went to got a
private tour of Zappos in Vegas it's
phenomenal I highly recommend this book
Tony's a stud with the way he explains
culture and he takes it to a whole
different level when you read I love
that book so here's what I want to
here's what I want to do I want to know
if you're the very serious type all
around the world where we are if you're
very serious or if you're loose so
here's a contest for you this is what
we'll do I want you to take the most
creative picture yourself the most
creative picture yourself and watching
value tainment so whatever the creative
pictures you watch in value tainment
let's see there's got to be a picture of
value taming there's got to be picture
with you in it and it's got to be
creative the most creative picture of
value tainment you take and either you
share it on facebook with hashtag
patrick be david or you take the picture
and post it on instagram with hashtag
patrick bid david and hashtag value
tainment we'll take the best picture
that's put on instagram with hashtag
Patrick Bay David a hashed value
tainment and the two most creative
pictures we will send you a copy of 25
loss for doing the impossible signed by
me that's a book I wrote myself 25 loss
for doing the impossible but I want to
see how much culture you got how
creative are you are you just a person
who's very square and everything's got
to be very you know perfectly done or
are you willing to loosen up a little
bit and have some fun so take the
picture with you watch and value taming
an episode of it and then be creative
put it on Instagram we'll put the
hashtag Patrick baited ilya let's make
sure we put the hashtag Patrick may
david in value tainment here and then
from there we'll reach out to you and
private message you and tell you hey
great pick send us your andres we're
gonna send you a signed book of doing
the impossible with that being said
if you got any questions if you got any
questions about what I just talked about
here any questions about what I just
talked about here
comment on the bottom if you like what I
just talked about on a PDF go to my
website Patrick Bay David comm if you
want this in PDF go to my website
Patrick Bay David calm there should be
one link on the bottom or if you're
watching this already on my website the
PDF should be on the bottom keep going
to the bottom you'll see PDF on the
bottom for you to subscribe to my weekly
newsletter if you subscribe to the
newsletter you will get the PDF sent to
you right off the bat so you can just
have this and go out there and look at
it within your business to see how
closely you run your culture on the way
we just talked about right now with that
being said thanks for watching and body
take care bye bye